[Music]  president ramaposa  how do you feel about what you've seen  today this is a horrible situation that  has befallen us but i'm really pleased  that  the people of our country have come  out to defend their hard-won freedom  and much as this terrible thing has  happened  they remain strong they remain firm  in their support of the government  we admit that there were lapses but  they are retaining their confidence  in what the government can do and they  want us to tighten things up which is  what we're going to do we've got to move  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  now  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  okay now it looks like i won't be able  to clean up  because there are so many of you but  thank you so much  thank you give it back to the baby thank  you so much  okay thank you so much